a second independence referendum now
very much
in play a pro-independence government in
scotland guaranteed
but without an outright majority the snp
will work as a team with the greens
scotland's first minister not wasting
any time in getting the ball rolling
scottish independence her goal it is
a commitment made to the people by a
clear majority
of the msps who have been elected to our
national parliament it is
the will of the country and given that
outcome
there is simply no democratic
justification
whatsoever for boris johnson or indeed
for anyone else
seeking to block the right of the people
of scotland
to choose our own future but calling for
a referendum is not the same as making
it happen
you can have a fight for a referendum
you can have a political fight and then
a legal fight
but you can't sit here now and tell me
that you can guarantee
a legal referendum for scottish people
by the end of 2024
that's factually true though let us
reflect on what we are actually talking
about here
true isn't it let's have a conversation
about what i
acknowledge that there is a risk that
the uk government may seek to block
democracy in scotland yes that is a risk
to do such a thing would be
extraordinary
it would be undemocratic it makes
independence inevitable
unionists say this is not a decision
scotland can make on its own
i'm not saying it has to go to the
supreme court the scottish government
would be legislating beyond their
competency and of course the
2014 referendum was held with what
nicholas stand
nicola sturgeon said was the gold
standard which was agreement between the
uk government
and the scottish government and that is
what the snp have always said
it was the right approach and listen to
the line
from westminster it really isn't the
time to
do constitutional tinkering and and have
you know another
divisive referendum i just don't think
uh that is what people want
and the government's very clear that
we've had a referendum
and that is not the time to have another
one but that government is a long
way away from here and hollyrood feels
very differently
people of scotland have elected a
government that's promised a second
independence referendum by the end of
2024
but whether it can deliver on that
promise is another matter
entirely the uk government can try
to block such a move via the supreme
court
so while an independence referendum's
far from guaranteed
what is nailed on is a constitutional
fight about it and that means that
politicians
up here will be able to set the agenda
in westminster the nations of this union
are bound by geography
and history but our values are diverging
and these elections
show it conservative england
snp scotland labour wales
and a uk prime minister with a firm
grasp on england
as the rest of the union threatens to
slip from his grip
beth rigby sky news hollyrood